lung cancer prevention includes actions
you can take to lower your chance of
developing
cancer the most important thing you can
do to prevent Lung Cancer is to not
start smoking or to quit smoking if you
do avoid breathing in other people
smoke test your home for Radon a known
carcinogen or cancer-causing
agent avoid exposure to cancer-causing
chemicals at
work maintain a healthy weight because
being overweight can cause the body to
circulate higher levels of certain
hormones that can stimulate cancer
growth eat a diet full of fruits and
vegetables which are packed with
substances that can help reduce your
risk of cancer and help control your
weight exercise regularly which will
help you control your weight and reduce
your risk through its positive influence
on your hormone levels and immune
system be sure and talk to your doctor
about ways to reduce your risk of lung
cancer